hat ja heute auch eine These mitgebracht
und die impliziert auch eine Lösung ja
muss alles aktivieren was wir an
energie-leistung bringen können einiges
macht die Region muss auch ein bisschen
okay dies sein der sie jetzt die
flüssige die schwimmenden Terminals
angeschafft hat oder gemietet hat
immerhin zwei bis Ende des Jahres gehen
wir den Flüssiggas ins Netz
hineinbringen kann ist ein Fortschritt
ich würde in der Tat da bin ich mit der
Gruppe auch einig wie wir es nach der
Wiedervereinigung gemacht haben die
Planungsverfahren auf Zeit verkürzen nur
eine widerspruchsebene nicht über x
Ebene hinein Widerspruchsmöglichkeiten
zu geben das muss aber denn durchhalten
und es machen und dann muss man auch
bereit sein entsprechende Veränderung zu
akzeptieren wir können das schon mal
ganz kurzfristig geht's nicht so gerne
da muss man schon ein bisschen Zeit
haben die nächsten zwei Jahren sind die
kritischen dieser Winter und 23 das sind
die beiden kritischen da müssen wir uns
behelfen mit Flüssiggas übrigens Amerika
immer gut funktioniert Frankreich
funktioniert nicht die Hälfte der
Kernkraftwerke sind nicht nutzbar
derzeit sind noch eine schlichtere
Technik einfach als Deutschland
verarbeitsweise nicht kühlen können und
B was sich gebaut trotzdem sind
funktionieren dabei und so waren viel
besser wir sind es ist halt mehr als
Entscheidung ich fahre andere Auffassung
länger genutzt immer draußen das kann
man nicht revidieren mehr das müssen und
den Gegebenheit möglichst das neu
justieren und man muss auch neue prüfen
ob wir nicht frech England machen und
ich würde alle drei Kernkraftwerke die
noch haben nutzen ist natürlich
Durchsicht die Wahltaktik von ein
Habicht des Niedersachsen wurde Liga
Landesverband der grün ist das war der
Landtagswahl 9 Oktober das nicht macht
um da möglichst viel Stimmen zu kriegen
Illusion zu wecken ist Politik aber
schlechte Politik
wir haben heute eine Entscheidung von
dann habe ich muss jetzt einmal dieses
wunderbare Mikrofon benutzen weil
offenbar mein anderes Mikrofon kaputt
ist deswegen nicht wundern warum ich
hier so ein Eis in der Hand halte aber
ich glaube das was heute passiert ist
das würde ein bisschen den widersprechen
was sie gerade gesagt haben mein Bruder
denn die kehrt werdet ihr habe heute
vollzogen hat Richtung AK Wände so
nennen wir das jetzt mal also zwei
mindestens zwei Kernkraftwerken zu
erlauben das reicht es eine andere Frage
bis ins Frühjahr 2023 im Netz zu bleiben
die Haut den seinen Parteifreundin
Niedersachsen so voll ins Kontor das
Shepherd bis hier nach Berlin die
plakativ mit bye bye AKW und der eigene
Wirtschaftsminister und bisherige
parteikode Gehirn sagt zwei Wochen vor
der Landtagswahl bei AKW machen wir
nicht wir lassen die Dinger länger am
Netz also da sheparts ganz gewaltig und
ich bin gespannt der hat ja zwei
Herausforderungen eigentlich einmal die
den die Wahl am 9 Oktober
und dann noch den Bundesparteitag heißt
der bundesregiertenversammlung eine
Woche später der einzige der sich freut
wissen Sie wer das ist das ist hapex
Schwager der
FDP-Spitzenkandidat Stephan Bürkner der
wird heute Abend sicherlich eine Flasche
Shampoos aufmachen und einen großen
Unterschied wenn wir regieren das habe
ich auch alles erlebt da muss man
Entscheidungen treffen als Opposition
kann so schön erklärt programmieren und
Sprüche für Landschaft tragen hast du
keine Verantwortung der Umsetzung dabei
jetzt am Abend drin ich muss unseren Amt
alt erfüllen und die beiden südlichen
Atomkraftwerke weit weg von
Niedersachsen da tut er sich vielleicht
außerdem will das nur bis April
verlängern ich würde sie 14 Jahre
verlängern aber er muss man muss dem
habe ich aber das auch sehr positiv
anrechnen dass er den Mut hat auch
sozusagen das jetzt zu verlängern was
für die für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland natürlich ganz wichtig ist
dass wir das weiter das kommt und da
muss ich sagen das wäre ein großer
Pluspunkt wie ist das für Habig dass er
den Mut hat gegen die freien Interessen
das als eben als Wirtschaftsminister
durchzusetzen und deshalb kriegt er
dafür sicherlich für mehr Pluspunkte als
er Negativpunkt
ich möchte ein bisschen Wasser in den
Wein schütten weil ganz ehrlich
hat jetzt quasi damals zwei von drei
entschieden weiterlaufen zu lassen eine
Entscheidung die seit Monaten überfällig
ist ja wo man sagt jeder der auch nur
halbwegs Verstand hat weil wusste das
muss weiterlaufen ich glaube das Herr
Habeck etwas ganz anderes taktisch
gerade tut dass er nämlich versucht den
letzten Rest Glaubwürdigkeit zu retten
den er vielleicht irgendwie in seiner
politischen Laufbahn noch retten möchte
denn spätestens nach der Wahl hätte er
sowieso einen knicken müssen aber der
Glaube ich ja schlecht auf ein Parteitag
stellen und sagen wir sind dagegen und
wir schaffen
also sie Glaubwürdigkeit innerhalb
seiner Partei setzt ja jetzt schon auf
Spiel es ist ja nicht so als wäre die
absolute Mehrheit der Grünen würden die
mir zujubeln na er kann ja sozusagen nur
eine Entscheidung als
Wirtschaftsminister treffen er kann ja
nicht sozusagen für seine Partei
entscheiden mit Sicherheit zusammen
macht wir haben doch Eiern gelernt dass
das Politiker nicht kein Partei und Land
grüner und hat das entschieden als
grüner Politiker
ie hat versucht sein eigenes Feld zu
retten weil er nämlich auch derjenige
sein müsste der nach dem Parteitag sich
nämlich hinstellt um nicht nur seine
eigene Partei sondern auch der gesamten
Öffentlichkeit in Deutschland zu
erklären dass das was auf ein Partei Tag
noch verkündet hat eine Woche später
nicht mehr gilt und damit wäre ja seine
eigene Glaubwürdigkeit als
Wirtschaftsminister völlig hinüber
Stromproduktion die der diskutiert
werden Joschka Fischer hat das gleiche
Gitarren die Grünen waren gegründet als
Anti atomkraftbewegung und
Friedensbewegung Joschka Fischer hat den
ersten auslandsansatz deutscher
Streitkräfte damals bei weitaus holen
mit Auschwitz begründet
Balkan möglich gemacht da hat er noch
den roten pfadbeutel da die Fresse
bekommen also
das ist schon Architekt was bleibt jetzt
über von den Grünen ich meine die Grünen
wurden gewählt für Krieg ohne Waffen die
Grünen wurden gewählt für keine
Verlängerung der Atomkraftwerke also was
bleibt langsam noch von der Partei über
wir werden natürlich für 100 Aspekte
gewählt sie werden nicht nur für zwei
Punkte gewählt deshalb haben wir alle
diese Programme die kein Mensch liest
aber sie hat sie dabei den Grünen ist
natürlich dass anti-akkw gehen so stark
wie kein anderer vergleichbar mit dem
keine Steuererhöhung oder Steuersenkung
gehen bei der FDP bei uns umstritten ich
war dafür
genau
also ich wollte noch mal sagen das hat
die AKB gehen bei den Grünen ist so
stark wie bei Ihnen das steuersenkungs
gehen also zumindest in der FDP von
daher ist das glaube ich was Robert
Habeck gemacht dann schon es ist möglich
der Kurs richtig verdient Mut verdient
Respekt bekommen zu dem Thema sicherlich
gleich noch einmal aber es ist mehr
glaube ich als ein wahltaktisches
Manöver es ist in dem Fall ähm ein eine
Entscheidung pro Deutschland und gegen
die eigene Mann
ganz kurz Unterbrechung und dann kommen
wir zu Robert Habeck